[Music]
[Applause]
sam amick the athletic uh said lebron
james would be quote very enthused at
the possibility of the lakers hiring
mark jackson as
head coach
i did reach out to mark jackson about 15
minutes ago and i said lakers question
mark and then mark said
uh my phone hasn't been ringing
that was it
a non-denial denial sam amick the uh
athletic reporter joining us on the
program
uh explain your conversation uh if you
can uh when did you have one with lebron
and uh what came out of that
good morning dan always great to be with
you um so he had his exit interview with
the media
in la yesterday 9 a.m
he wanted to get it out of the way early
which i found fascinating everybody else
went in the afternoon
lebron had regular life to get back to
so he jumped on zoom
uh
i i was not there in person so i jumped
on and and asked him specifically about
the messiness of the vogel firing and
whether or not the lack of
professionalism bothered him at all
so that was the uh that was the dialogue
with him yesterday and then
like you said on the intro here uh you
know a lot more information in the
column itself okay but what did he say
about the
professionalism of the uh the
organization how they handled frank
vogel
i mean like i wrote so it's like to me
and
the short version was translated in my
mind as i just work here you know what i
mean which is obviously not the case but
he kind of had a a vibe about him of he
went through this whole thing it's just
like sam you know
i knew uh when i was talking to you all
this morning so i got up extra early so
i could take my daughter to school
dropped her off at school came down and
he went through this whole thing about
his day and he and he said i was three
minutes late to talk to you guys i
apologize he was talking to his media
advisor adam mendelson on the side
before jumping on zoom
and uh and so at the end of it he just
essentially said
you can't control uh how you know people
feel about the way you handle your
business it kind of it is what it is
essentially and it wasn't to me it
wasn't dismissive of frank
at all it was just another example of a
lebron kind of looking around in laker
land and saying i'm not going to
be held accountable for all the the
weirdness that occasionally happens
around here what did frank vogel do or
not do that cost him his job
i mean that's a great question i mean
the obvious is just not win ball games i
think it's as simple as that and then
because he didn't in my opinion if you
know you could argue that he he you know
you hear the adage of just you you lost
your players i don't think it's that
simple because there was not acrimony
between frank and his players other than
in my opinion russell westbrook
um you know and i think that
frank tried his best to make the
westbrook situation work
but
you know this was a disastrous season
for a team that you know that vegas had
winning the whole thing i believe going
into the season so
um it's
just that and really i think it's also a
lack of connectivity
between frank and the front office that
i would put on the front office that you
know rob polinka is
it's an interesting time to be robbed
because when he won the championship
and
after the magic johnson experience it
was obviously all over the headlines i
get winning it all
masked a lot of
the kind of internal dysfunction
that i think was there the entire time
and now we are seeing it kind of rear
its head again so
to your question about frank i just
think it's it's the accountability
question they lost ball games
you're not going to fire lebron and say
hey you wanted russ so you're out of
here that doesn't happen
um and then
rob is kind of you know in my opinion
mostly wiping his hands of this even
though he built the roster
uh until frank ends up being the fall
guy
yeah i just wonder about this the the
disconnect with russell westbrook and
frank vogel
that
how was frank supposed to use russell
westbrook that he didn't use him in that
way i mean he did play
the most minutes and he did play 78
games so russ was on the floor more than
anybody else
he was i to me it's just it's a painful
um
process when
elite
you know future hall of fame players
have to come to grips with the fact that
they're just in a different stage and
you know there's been i think apt
comparisons made between russ
and alan iverson um you know hopefully
he has a
uh kind of a a better exit than allen
did when you know he's in memphis and
detroit um but that's where russ is is
this question of like he i he talked a
lot about sacrifice yesterday
and i do understand that he made some
with this team but i think deep down he
still
gets up in the morning feeling like he
can be russell westbrook the guy who
averaged triple double however many
times and former mvp and so
you know he's not ready to let that go
um and more importantly
even if he is
that's what's always made him great and
we have not seen
some kind of watered-down version of his
his game where you see an evolution to
where he can be an impact player off the
ball
defensively you know doing the little
things that that profile has never
existed and so you know i just think if
you're frank you're you're sitting there
shaking your head like what am i
supposed to do here yeah because you
have a player who still thinks he's
russell westbrook of seven years ago and
you can't change him at 34. he still
can't shoot
um he has it it's almost like his body
and his mind work really fast but they
don't always work in unison and
that that he and i love the effort that
he gives it's just sometimes it's the
effort that gets him in trouble and i
don't know if you're going to
i'm going to get lebron at
season 20 i get westbrook i guess i get
anthony davis and then what else am i
getting is this an attractive job
right absolutely uh and you're not alone
by the way with your analysis of
his mind and body you know just kind of
having a bit of a
sync problem there if you will it's you
know we saw that moment courtside in the
regular season when shaq
kind of chirped at him a little bit to
tell him to slow down
there's some people with the lakers who
have tried to to find solutions here
with with that kind of mentality of you
know how do we get the best out of russ
and i'm dying to see going forward i
mean i know everybody assumes he's going
to get traded i don't know if it's going
to be as easy as people think so you
know for all i know i mean maybe they
end up having to run it back
and and talk him into being a sixth man
i mean it's unlikely but
um
it was an uncomfortable year and on a
human level at times i did feel bad for
russ because
we can all at least appreciate the idea
that he grew up in the city comes back
thinks it's going to be you know the
stuff of childhood dreams and and he
becomes
kind of the poster boy for one of the
most infamous teams probably in league
history
how did the name mark jackson come up
with your conversation with lebron
no that was uh to you know and you know
how our jobs are that was reporting um
that i will just say you know was
confidently gleaned
that that he would give a big thumbs up
to mark that was not part of the zoom
conversation oh okay okay yeah yeah that
was
that was uh you know
that was relayed to me
i will say though it's it's you know
this the politics of this
league oh it never ceased to amaze me
it's like
he
did there is a
an understandable
uh desire from you know his side and his
camp
to you know they're very sensitive to
the idea that
that he's pulling the strings with the
lakers and i think they make some really
good points so like on the mark jackson
front
i tried to write it as accurately and
delicately as possible he just would he
would give a big thumbs up if they hired
mark jackson that's not me saying he's
internally pushing for mark and saying
mark jackson or else because
lebron knows that that you know the
second that he does that
it becomes a story and we all know that
he did push for the westbrook trade and
now that's partly on his unofficial kind
of gm resume so
it's it's mark is a guy i mean mark's
got a ton
of superstar support in this league and
so the longer he doesn't have a head
coaching job i think this kind of noise
will only get louder
but in terms of lebron and av
and the makeup of this locker room the
way it was relayed to me
is that they they would react well to
somebody like mark who could command the
room
and you know come in with the respect of
the stars and role players alike
and that uh lebron's not alone there's
quite a few guys that think that would
be a good excuse me a good fit yeah but
it i've always got this feeling i'm
friends with mark and uh you know we've
had conversations of why he's not
getting another job it feels like the
players
are all in it doesn't feel like the
front office is all in with mark jackson
would you say that's fair
yeah i would um to that point i found it
somewhat fascinating you know i wrote
the story our
place published it this morning and
they found a picture of mark jackson
talking to
rob
and that picture in and of itself made
me wonder like i don't know the exact
state of that relationship that is the
sort of thing you know that would matter
um the backstory though as you know
is one that is you know it's probably
uh needs more time to be analyzed but i
mean his warrior's exit was was messy um
you know i think that joe lacob and that
group
um were frustrated with him at that time
to a point where you know
parts of that experience stuck with him
as he's left in terms of his reputation
uh and there's other stuff too i mean
you know there's you know jason collins
or jaren collins comments rather that
that you know are tough to get away from
in today's climate uh and i think
like i mean everybody's made mistakes so
every candidate these days is going to
have stuff to work through uh with the
organization that they're possibly going
to work with and
i will say though this is the first time
for me in a while where you're starting
to feel like the ground swell with mark
might tip a bit to where you navigate
those waters and
and eventually see them on the sideline
again well those pe players better be
ready because mark is a
hard-nosed guy a no-nonsense guy he
i don't know if he's a player's coach
but he he demands he demands you know
accountability
i'll say this much quickly though dan on
that front um one of the thriving forces
i think in terms of his reputation being
in good shape with players now is that
publicly privately if you
go at a steph curry a draymond green and
clay thompson
guys that he was obviously sharing the
room with for years they continued to
speak highly of the the impact he had on
them and the way that he kind of set the
tone for what they accomplished once he
was gone so
um that kind of stuff matters a great
deal and uh and again there's a lot of
support from mark
sam great job it's great to talk to you
again thanks for joining us on short
notice
you got it thank you dan all right sam
amick the uh senior nba writer for the
athletic